you
hi everyone it's Jerry this is video 19
from the beginner to chess master
playlist which is a progressive series
of videos and I'd like to share with you
a very popular rook and pawn endgame
position this one here known as the
Lucena position rook and pawn end games
are the most popular type of end games
in chess the Lucena position more
specifically is one of the most popular
of them it is this position type is one
that I have encountered in many of my
own games whether it be over the board
play competitive games tournament games
or online games this pops up quite a bit
and in short is a must know I will be
sharing with you a universal method to
winning this type of an endgame but
before I do that let me go ahead and
describe what the Lucena position looks
like so that you know when it is present
in one of your own games one of the well
the primary feature of the Lucena
position has one side with a pawn plus
white in this case the stronger side and
the stronger sides King is in front of
that pawn okay that right there is the
primary feature of the Lucena position
also we have the defending sides rook
contributing in a way where it is
interfering with what it is white would
like to do well what is it
like would like to do in this endgame
well white would like to move the King
out of the pawns way and then push the
pawn through the rook is interfering
with that idea the rook has we might say
some file influence okay those are the
two key features I would say to
identifying
the Lucena position now in this specific
case we're working with you can also
observe the defending sides King is
contributing to not allowing the King
get out of the pawns way as well but we
can also have the king elsewhere maybe
somewhere over here and we would still
define this or describe this position
type as the Lucena position okay so with
that said let me actually give you just
a little bit of a preview of how this
position looked just a few moves ago
nothing nothing sophisticated I just
want to give you a little bit of a taste
as to how we got to that position white
being on move he's getting the pawn
rolling black king is getting involved
white gets out of the pawns way black
throw some pressure on the pawn pawn
pushes the rook is there to now have
some influence there we go okay we're at
this position this key position we want
to know how exactly to win it from here
now I'd like to make just one adjustment
as a start here currently the rook is on
g1 okay I'm going to shift him over to
be one for just a moment it's white to
move what would we do here now it may be
very tempting to move the white King in
this position seeing that there is this
how to say some type of coordinated
effort apparently with stopping the King
from getting out of the pawns way like
so but there appears to be no one
stopping the King from getting out of
the pawns way on this side so why not
just play to King g7 right now well we
won't be able to make progress if we
move the King to g7 or even g8 moving
the King out of the pawns way at this
moment here will not lead us to any
progress let's see why okay suppose King
g7 what's the issue with this
we're ready to promote on our next move
unfortunately this is not a stable
square for our King and he could end up
getting checked and will get checked
like crazy
starting with rook g1 where does the
King go King h6 rook h1 wherever the
king goes he's going to get checked if
he goes too far away let's say something
like this if he's moving away he'll just
grab the pawn something like this if
he's going too far away like so we get
right behind the pawn and how are you
saving the pawn you could only do it for
one move but soon enough he will be
tracked down short story here is that
moving the King right now at this moment
is no good something needs to change
what must that change be it has to
involve the rook the key move here a
simple way to win this position is to
play rook to g2 as a start
what is this rook doing it's providing a
shield from checks first we play two
rook on g2 and only then get the King to
the G file and push the pawn through
suppose King e6 or in fact let's say
rook f1 first King g8 blackett try to
stop the pawn like this but we can now
give a check in next promote this is
simple enough if we have this type of
position present where you know both the
king you have the the defending side the
king and the rook are both focused on
just one side of the pond we can move
the rook like so first and make sure
that once we do move our King out of the
pawns way he will be shielded from rook
checks
okay that's simple enough but let's
consider our initial position one where
there is this where the rook is guarding
one side and the King is guarding the
other what to do now clearly we can't
play root 2 G 1 that would not be best
but what we can do is insert this check
and rattle
the defending sides King position now
where does he go let's consider yz6 as a
start what would we do here kingi eight
and then push through next no successful
way to stop that there is no mating idea
by black because we can always block
this check so that would be simple
enough starting with this check if the
King goes to e6 we go to e8 and push
through next suppose however black goes
to c7 what would we do now
here is the key idea this this method
that I'm sharing with you here is here's
the key move in this position and that
is rook to d4
you'll notice something with you know
that initial position this one right
here if the King goes out too early all
these you know the rook comes over here
and starts giving the check in this
example there was never a moment where
our rook was able to successfully shield
those checks or block those checks
however if we move our rook a little bit
closer to our King if we position our
rook in such a way where there are now
just two ranks separating the separating
the rook and the pond he is now in a
position to one day shield our King from
checks let's see how rook ji to
basically a passing move there isn't a
good move for black to play here let's
just go with King Cobra to g2 King e7
check check check and eventually after
another check we're able to now block
our rook is providing a shield against
these rook checks rook takes rook King
takes rook we promote next okay so this
is really the method here we want to
optimize our rook position before we
move our king out of the pond
way and we do that by positioning him
such that there are two ranks between
the rook and the pawn I'd like to show
one other variation this one here where
after this check suppose the King does
not play to c7 but instead c6 okay we
yet again can play rook to d4 to ranks
still between the rook and the pond but
in this case instead of making this bit
of a passing move with droop to g2
suppose black says no I'm going to
attack the rook now that I'm at least a
little bit closer before he was over
here but now that he's on c6 suppose he
goes to c5 and attacks the rook now what
Black's idea might be aha
you could go here I'll take your rook
and you'll have to try to win this
position no we can simply meet the
threat against our rook in play right
behind the pond and the next move will
get our King out of the pawns way and
then push through you'll notice the
drawback connected with the rook
attacking or the King attacking the rook
if he's attacking the rook that means he
will not be around to guard these two
squares the King will be able to get out
in this way so he could do one of the
two he could either attack the rook or
he could try to stop the King from going
to one of these two squares but he
cannot do both so after rook to f4 I
guess this is one of the better tries
nothing is really a great try at that
stage after King d6 King to e8
and eventually we are going to promote
and in fact in this case we will be
promoting with check okay I guess one
other idea might be after rip to f4
if worked to e1 well we can get out of
the prawns way on the other side and
even go here yet again notice our rook
is providing a nice shield against any
of these file checks and will be able to
push through soon enough okay one other
variation to cover and it is this one
here after this initial checking idea
and King to c7 let's say we go for this
rook lift rook g2 now our King comes out
only after we have optimized our rook
check check and suppose at this point
black stops with the checks and says you
know what if I go to e2 White's going to
go to f5 and if I check again there's
just going to be that little shielding
idea that little blocking idea so
therefore once I get to this point here
maybe black doesn't give this next check
suppose black just kind of makes a
waiting move with the King King to c6
what do we do now what can we do now
well we can insist on interfering with
the rook seeing our pond we could try to
get our rook in between the black rook
and our pawn namely the f5 square in
this case but we just need to be a
little bit delicate about how we do that
we want to go to d5 and then f5 however
going to d5 right away is no good
because there is this tactical shot the
rook can capture the pawn and on King
takes rook there's King takes rook in
this is of course a draw so the one
little adjustment we make here is to
simply give a check first and now
whether or not whether the King goes to
c7 the seventh rank or the fifth rank
we're going to d5 next King c5 notice
rook d5 is hitting with check and then
we get here next there's a check our
rook is shielding ensuing file checks
we're able to push through next
or after we insert this check if the
King goes to the seventh rank now we
could go to d5 and the difference here
is that the King does not have direct
pressure on our rook right he is not
there attacking our rook so there is now
not this tactical idea of capturing the
pawn and then getting our rook on the
next move there is no pressure on our
rook in this position okay so that's
just one little variation still the same
idea where the what we're trying to do
is position our Brooke so that he can
one day shield against these rook checks
shield our King against these rook
checks so we position him to ranks in
between the rook and the pawn and then
we move our king out and eventually
we'll be able to shield our King from
the checks and push our pond through now
this method that I just showed is one
that we can apply to non rip pawns okay
I just happen to show it with an F con
but this method applies to the b c d e f
and g pawns okay the rook pawns are you
can't sometimes it's impossible to win
against rook pawns and we're going to
have a look at just a few examples as a
close let's see why so tricky or why we
can't win in some situations like this
well the defensive task is a lot simpler
we can observe unless there's some file
I okay you know the king isn't going to
be able to get out of the pawns way like
so so the defensive task for black is
much easier we can see both the rook and
the King stop the King from getting out
in this way and there isn't a good way
for white to you know flush both the
rook and King away from the g8 and g7
squares in this case
you can do this but after King here
you're not chasing the rook away one try
might be something like this and then
putting the rook on g8 if rook takes
rook okay yeah we recapture and promote
and we're going to win but you just
don't capture rook to e1 and how are you
dislodging the king you're not okay you
could you could dislodge one one of the
two but not both is basically what's
what it's coming down to you can
dislodge the king
you could dislodge the rook but you
cannot do both let's have a look at a
position another position where the king
is just a little further away even this
position right here is a draw if the
white rook can get to this square right
here in just one move from this position
that would be great
you could just move like a bishop for a
moment this would be a win but it's
going to take him two moves you would
have to go to a eight and then get here
from it would have to be White's move
again at this point but it's black on
move and the King could get over just in
time and as we have already seen this
will not amount to anything here's an
example where it would be a win the King
is now a bit too far away now this would
be the winning idea for white rook e8
King tries to get over in time but we
have rook to g8 let's say rook h1 now
the king can get out King g7 we can have
a few checks thrown out there and
eventually the King can you know all
these checks will be exhausted soon
enough there's a check here check there
why Kings just exacts his way out
rook h1 we now have that promotion
Square covered by our rook and we will
go on to win so a little bit trickier of
course working with the rook pawns the
main feature however is ones where we're
working with non repens
in this position type here again
side with a pawn plus here stronger side
white King in front of the pawn
defending sides rook having some file
influence interfering with what it is
white would like to do getting the King
out of the pawns way and then pushing
through this is the lucena position and
again a very good method is to optimize
our rook and ultimately have him act as
a shield against rook checks okay so
that's all for this video as always I
hope you got something out of it and
feel free to leave any comments in the
comment section below that's all for now
take care bye
you